[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat de
reportage et d'analyse sur Public Sénat
vous le savez la promesse et dans le
titre donner du sens à l'actualité vous
proposez les clés de compréhension des
mutations de notre société 90 minutes et
deux grands thèmes d'actu aujourd'hui
les femmes d'abord les femmes seront
elles les grandes perdantes de la
réforme des retraites la réponse
gouvernementale est un peu cacophonique
depuis 24 heures entrée Elisabeth borne
Frank Riester et Olivier du soft on va
tenter d'y voir plus clair et poser
aussi la question plus politique d'un
soutien qui devient chaque jour un peu
plus friable celui des députés elle est
et puis la loi sur les jeux olympiques
et discuter depuis ce matin au Sénat des
peines plus lourdes pour les intrusions
les violences dans les stades une vidéo
surveillance renforcée et un défi
majeurs le jour de la cérémonie
d'ouverture le 26 juillet
600 000 personnes dans l'hypersens de
Paris le long de la Seine avec des noms
problèmes d'ordre public si jamais les
choses se passaient évidemment mal
la sécurité des jeux se fera-t-elle au
détriment de nos libertés ce sera la
question centrale de notre débat dans
trois quarts d'heure mais d'abord donc
cette réforme des retraites les gagnants
les perdants avec Flora sauvage si la
réforme des retraites prévoit de reculer
l'âge légal de départ de 62 à 64 ans
tous les travailleurs ne sont pas logés
à la même enseigne globalement ceux qui
sont nés après 1961 sont perdants car
ils devront travailler deux ans de plus
progressivement les carrières longues
sont aussi pénalisées ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler avant 16 et 18 ans
devront cotiser non pas 43 mais 44 ans
et effectivement ils auront à travailler
44 ans pour pouvoir bénéficier de la
mesure en conséquence ce sera le travail
du Parlement voir si on peut pas
rétablir une meilleure justice encore
par rapport à ce dispositif de carrière
longue le recul de l'âge légal de départ
à la retraite va aussi pénaliser les
femmes avec la réforme elle
travailleront sept mois supplémentaires
en moyenne contre 5 mois pour les hommes
car le report de l'âge légal à 64 ans
fait perdre aux femmes le bénéfice des
trimestres pour enfants des trimestres
qui leur donnent actuellement le droit à
un départ anticipé si vous reportez
l'âge légal elles sont évidemment un peu
pénalisés par ce report de l'âge légal
au nom dix convient absolument pas du
côté des gagnants la réforme si elle est
votée telle qu'elle devrait permettre
d'augmenter les pensions des retraités
les plus pauvres avec la revalorisation
du minimum de pension jusqu'à 1200 euros
beaucoup de gens entendent minimum
retraite 1150 euros par mois parfait
même si je n'ai pas travaillé
durant 43 ans non il faudra réellement
avoir travaillé
le nombre de trimestres requis en
fonction de son année de naissance mais
ça c'est une avancée je ne vais pas le
nier c'est la seule à mon sens qu'il y a
dans ce projet de réforme des retraites
selon le gouvernement le relèvement de
l'âge de départ à 64 ans permettra
d'augmenter le niveau de pension des
retraités tout en assurant la pérennité
du système par répartition
les gagnants les perdants en restent sur
cette question dans notre débat avec mes
invités Stéphanie Villers bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes conseiller
économique à PwC France Bruno palier
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi directeur
de recherche au CNRS au Centre d'étude
européenne de Sciences Po et auteur de
ce livre réformé les retraites publiées
au presse de Sciences Po qui retrace
l'historique de nos systèmes de retraite
a fait le gendre bonsoir bienvenue
Raphaël journaliste à l'opinion et
Mathilde Sirault bonsoir bienvenue
Mathilde sur le plateau de sens public
éditorialiste politique pour toute cette
émission voilà en remplacement de
Laetitia cruppa à qui on fait un coucou
très amical alors les gagnants les
perdants je vous cache pas au sein de la
rédaction de de sens public il y a
quelques voix qui sont élevés de toute
façon il y a que des perdants sauf que
si on regarde la communication du
gouvernement tiens Olivier du sob
c'était dans le Journal du Dimanche ce
week-end il n'y a pas de perdant nous
dit le ministre du Travail les gagnants
de la réforme ce sont les Français les
plus modestes qui ont eu des carrières
hachées les femmes et aussi l'ensemble
des Français qui amélioreront leur
pension on vient l'entendre dans le
sujet de de Flora sauvage que Franck
Rister disait plutôt que les femmes
étaient perdantes bref on va reparler de
la communication du gouvernement
évidemment Stéphanie Villers je commence
avec est-ce que c'est un peu gonflé
quand même de la part de d'Olivier du
socle il y a pas de perdant de dire ça
en fait parce que j'imagine qu'il
suppose que le fait de prendre ses
mesures permettra de maintenir le
système par répartition cela dit on sait
ce que ça ça coûte puisque
collectivement on va devoir travailler
plus longtemps c'est ce qui est
d'ailleurs déclenche la grogne et les
grèves parce que les l'opinion oblique a
mal perçu en fait notre système et
comprend pas pourquoi aujourd'hui en
fait on devrait travailler plus
longtemps alors que les générations
précédentes sont partis
à des des unages moins élevé donc ils
ont l'impression qu'il paye trop et qui
payent plus par rapport aux générations
passées mais ça s'explique comptablement
en fait parce que effectivement
on a un taux de fécondité qui est assez
faible un taux de de d'actif sur les
retraités qui en diminution vous avez
entendu les chiffres partout on est 1,7
actif par retraités on était à 4 actifs
au début du système donc évidemment ça
pèse de plus en plus sur les actifs et
on a
avec on a aussi le décalage de
l'espérance de vie qui est une très
bonne nouvelle mais quand l'espérance de
vie va jusqu'à 82 ans et on part à 62
ans ça fait 20 ans de cotisations qui
repose sur les épaules des actifs donc
le gagnant c'est le système de
répartition si j'entends c'est un
collectivement on va dire
si on cherche des gagnants tiens parce
qu'on va beaucoup parler des perdants je
pense dans ce débat est-ce qu'on peut
dire quand même les retraités actuels
c'est gagnant par rapport à quoi c'est
un petit peu ça la question donc là
votre question elle sous-entend gagnant
par rapport au fait qu'on les a pas mis
à contribution c'est ça donc oui les
retraités actuels dont on sait qu'en
moyenne ils ont un revenu super à celui
des actifs si on inclut le patrimoine il
sentir plutôt bien alors le problème
c'est que dans les retraités actuels il
y a une bonne moitié dans le revenu
disparité aussi des retraites
relativement basses mais il faut quand
même rappeler que il faut comparer les
choses comparables le taux de pauvreté
des retraités il est il est faible
inférieur à 10% le taux de retraité des
jeunes et pas loin de 20% donc voilà il
y a deux si on parle de solidarité
intergénérationnelle il y a ces points
là donc oui les retraités actuels
ne sont pas mis à contribution ce qui
est totalement par un dogs par rapport à
la communication du gouvernement puisque
le gouvernement nous dit en un système
trop généreux mais ne demande pas aux
bénéficiaires de ce système très
généreux de contribuer donc ça c'est
quelques raisons politiques c'est très
clair là pour le coup de toute façon ce
qui échappent le plus aux conséquences
de la réforme c'est les entreprises et
les entrepreneurs pas de cotisations
sociales c'est une grande partie des
cadres et des très diplômés puisque ils
savaient déjà que ils allaient cotiser
longtemps et ils ont la forme pour le
faire ils vont rester en emploi et c'est
les retraités c'est les trois électorats
principaux de de la majorité du
gouvernement donc là il y a pas de il y
a pas de mystère là dessus par contre
sur des sujets comme les retraites qui
engagent non pas un groupe contre un
autre dans un coin de la société Mika
engage vraiment toute la société on voit
bien que à chaque fois qu'on débat des
retraites de les réformes des retraites
se mobilisent beaucoup de monde parce
que tout le monde se sent concernés un
jour je serai retraité 98% des gens se
forcés ou je suis à la retraite avoir ce
type de calcul de profilage de réforme
pour pas toucher son électorat et
peut-être un petit peu risqué bon on
peut en débattre de ça mais Raphaël
Legendre il y a souvent on dit sucré ou
salé pour pour évoquer ce type de
réforme est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup de
sucré et qu'est-ce qu'on entend par
sucré c'est les mesures sociales en fait
mesure sucrées sont les mesures de
redistribution et il se trouve que cette
réforme est beaucoup plus sucrée que
celle par exemple
mener en 2017
Nicolas Sarkozy les calculs sont très
simples c'est un tiers de sucré pour
deux tiers de Salé cette réforme elle
vise à combler un déficit qui est qui
serait
d'un peu plus de 13 milliards en 2030
grâce à cette réforme on va dégager près
de 18 milliards d'euros d'économie c'est
presque 6 milliards qui vont être
effectivement redistribués notamment
notamment dans le minimum ce qui
s'appelle le minimum contributif les
petites retraites pour ceux qui auront
cotisé à temps plein dont on a beaucoup
parlé effectivement ce sont ces fameux
1200 euros
c'est aussi beaucoup de salés dans le
fait qu'elle ne touchera pas tout le
monde est loin de là cette réforme on
râle beaucoup mais il faut compris que
seuls 60% des actifs seront touchés par
cette augmentation de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite puisque on va
renforcer à la fois la prévention mais
aussi les possibilités de partir plus
tôt sur les carrières longues sont ceux
qui ont travaillé avant ont commencé
travailler avant 20 ans et puis pour
tous ceux qui seront abîmés sur la
pénibilité dont on n'a pas fini
d'entendre parler notamment dans
l'examen parlementaire qui arrive alors
on va à la fois il y aura un chapitre
vraiment sur on va dire l'aspect un peu
plus politique la communication le jeu
DLR mais on va essayer de se concentrer
sur certaines catégories ou certains
aspects de la réforme des retraites et
je voudrais commencer par la question de
des femmes les femmes grandes perdantes
de cette réforme c'est ce que nous
disent nos confrères du Parisien
regardez cette infographie publiée donc
dans Le Parisien Aujourd'hui en France
par exemple on va prendre un comparatif
pour un homme né en 66 il devra
travailler 5 mois de plus avec la
réforme 7 mois pour une femme si on
regarde
1972 pour celles qui sont nées en 72
c'est pire 9 mois de travail
supplémentaire contre 5 mois pour les
hommes de la même classe d'âge alors
Bruno pas il y a des mesures de
compensation
pour les femmes ou qui font qui
bénéficieront
est-ce que ça commence pas suffisamment
quoi il faut bien dire que compensation
ça veut dire quoi c'est moins pire que
ça ne l'aurait été si on n'avait pas
fait de compensation mais de toute façon
c'est quand même pire puisque même quand
on dit ils auront une meilleure retraite
c'est une deuxième meilleure retraite
mais deux ans plus tard donc je pense
que il faut bien quand on parle de
redistribution etc c'est pas mieux
qu'avant ni d'ailleurs pour les
carrières longues ça c'est le premier
point le deuxième point c'est c'est tout
à fait étonnant de se retrouver dans ces
situations là qui à mon avis n'étaient
pas prévues quand on a quand ils ont
pensé cette réforme c'est un effet
pervers inattendu et je dois dire que
c'est tout l'intérêt d'avoir un débat
d'être en démocratie d'avoir de la
délibération c'est de prendre conscience
de choses qu'on n'avait pas vu et qui
sont rattrapables dans le débat
parlementaire mais c'est un sacré
paradoxe puisque notre système de
retraite est déjà très anti
redistributif vis-à-vis des femmes les
femmes touche en revenu médian direct de
droit direct 1100 euros les hommes c'est
1900 euros les femmes touchent donc 28%
de moins que les hommes à la retraite
pourquoi parce que elle travaille plus
souvent un temps partiel parce que elles
ont des années d'interruption et on
avait cherché un système de compensation
qui était les trimestres pour éducation
et c'est trimestres pour éducation ils
vont plus jouer puisque il faudra
attendre plus longtemps pour partir donc
là on est dans un effet multiplicateur
d'un système d'entraide qui lui-même
démultiplier les inégalités hommes sur
le marché du travail c'est tout à fait
étonnant mais l'intérêt du débat c'est
d'avoir révélé ça je pense que
c'est intéressant je vous donne la
parole juste après
et à l'autre mais j'entends vos
arguments mais alors quand on va
entendre à l'instant là tout de suite
Elisabeth borne c'est pas du tout le
même son de cloche sur cette question
des femmes grandes perdante ou pas de la
réforme écoutons la première ministre
au contraire nous réduisons les
inégalités inacceptables entre les
femmes et les hommes au moment de la
retraite nous protégeons nous protégeons
les femmes qui ont des carrières
incomplètes et hachées les femmes qui
ont commencé à travailler tôt les femmes
qui ont des petites pensions les femmes
seront les premières bénéficiaires de la
revalorisation des petites pensions
elles sont aujourd'hui plus nombreuses à
avoir cotisé avec des revenus modestes
et grâce à la revalorisation de la
retraite minimale près d'un tiers
d'entre elles vont voir leur pension
augmenter
par ailleurs nous prendrons prendreons
désormais en compte pour le calcul des
droits les trimestres en congés parental
voilà Isabelle bande c'était aujourd'hui
à l'Assemblée nationale les questions au
Gouvernement je vais vous donner la
parole évidemment Bruno pallier mais
Stéphanie Villard votre avis sur ce
point ce point précis c'est cynique de
la part d'Elizabeth borne de nous dire
que à celles les principales
bénéficiaires parce que de toute manière
pendant leur vie active c'était les plus
pauvres et que on va faire un effort sur
les la catégorie qui touche le moins
durant toute la vie active on va essayer
de gonfler
la pension de ces retraités les plus
défavorisés donc voilà le problème il
est il est global il est le problème de
la rémunération des femmes pendant leur
activité qui se reportent au moment et
qui même s'amplifie au moment de la
retraite parce que déjà ils ont des
revenus plus faibles ils ont des
carrières moins longues et
généralement haché pourquoi pour
en fait elle contribue c'est celle qui
contribue le plus à notre système de
répartition pourquoi parce qu'elles font
des enfants et c'est pas je me suis pas
sûr qu'avec huit trimestres de
compensation par enfant on arrive à
maintenir le système de maintenir le
système c'est regarder le taux de
fécondité en particulier il n'y a pas
que ça il peut y avoir l'immigration
tout ça mais enfin c'est regarder le
taux de fécondité un taux de fécondité
qui est en dessous de pour de deux
enfants par femme c'est déjà on sait que
c'est un système qui est déséquilibré
qu'on fait quand on repose la solidarité
intergénation générale c'est à dire que
les retraites sont payées par les actifs
bah s'il y a pas d'enfants il y a pas
d'actifs oui donc en fait il faudrait en
fait avoir une vision beaucoup plus
précise et globale en disant bah notre
système il marche c'est il y a une
natalité suffisante alors
raphaëlité on l'a vu récemment encore
avec les derniers chiffres qui
s'effondre effectivement et donc on
prépare un peu cet avenir et et donc la
solution derrière bien évidemment c'est
de rallonger la durée de travail un
effort qu'on ne doit porter
collectivement ce qu'on entend pas
beaucoup mais qui est absolument
nécessaire pour préserver encore une
fois la pérennité notre système par
répartition vous dites quoi il y a pas
vraiment d'alternative je dis que c'est
une réforme forcément douloureuse c'est
à dire que la durée l'âge
en bonne expérience de vie en plus salon
je rentre plus tard sur le marché du
travail et qu'on est en France à des
derniers européens pays européens à
pouvoir partir à avoir un âge légal à 62
ans qu'on est le pays européen qui
dépense le plus par rapport à sa
production de richesse nationale pour
nos retraités pour nos seniors qu'on a
des seniors qui ont un niveau de vie
moyen supérieur à celui des actifs
aujourd'hui et qu'il y a peut-être un
rééquilibrage pour revenir dans la
moyenne de ce qui se pratique partout
ailleurs en Europe manifestement vous
êtes pas d'accord non mais sur les
compagnons je pense qu'il faut être
précis en Suède on peut aussi partir
après 62 ans après c'est le principe il
y a quatre pays en Europe
aucun pays en Europe
le problème qu'on a dans ce débat c'est
que des choses sont lâchées qui sont pas
précises et pas exactes et ça crée du
doute il y a plusieurs pays où on peut
partir après 62 ans le chiffre qui
compte c'est le là j'effectif de départ
c'est à 63 ans les Italiens dépensent
plus que nous en pourcentage de PIB en
retraite donc voilà je mettons les
choses très précisément sur le sur la
table ça laisse 25 pays qui dépensent
moins
on est complètement dans le haut du
panier européenne le problème c'est de
moyenniser les choses de dire oui nous
avons un système de retrait plutôt
généreux mais pour qui pour ceux les
hommes qui sont capables de faire des
retraites à temps plein en travaillant à
temps plein et cotiser les choses sur le
minimum contributif je pense qu'il faut
bien rappeler une chose on a le temps de
la technicité le principe du calcul des
retraites en France il est proportionnel
ses proportionnelle à au temps que vous
avez cotisé il faut aller à 43 ans mais
c'est proportionnelle aussi à ce que
vous touchiez avant et si vous à temps
partiel vous allez toucher quelque chose
partielle par rapport à la retraite et
donc les 1200 euros c'est le max qu'on
puisse avoir et les femmes qui sont à
temps partiel elles n'auront pas 1200
euros plus la question qui n'est pas
résolue dans les débats et on ne sait
pas encore c'est est-ce qu'on est sur un
critère très strict qui est il faut
avoir été toute sa carrière au SMIC pour
pouvoir bénéficier de la valorisation et
ça fait pas grand monde ou alors est-ce
que ça va être une espèce de haut c'est
un peu généralisée promise à tous c'est
à dire en fait quand je dis oh c'est
d'établir un plancher plus élevé
qu'aujourd'hui pour les débats
parlementaires vont peut-être permettre
de le préciser c'est tout à fait ça et
c'est le point que je tenais à faire là
il y a les invectives
à l'Assemblée etc je crois que ce qui
est vraiment intéressant de de cette
période comme on vit c'est en période de
débat où l'on découvre des choses qu'on
n'avait pas vu avant y compris pourquoi
pas le gouvernement mais c'est pour ça
qu'on leur demande de faire des études
d'impact c'est pour ça qu'il y a des
experts c'est pour qu'il y a des
instituts indépendants voilà c'est
l'avantage d'être dans une démocratie
moi j'ai envie de je peux le dire sur
cette chaîne de télé c'est tout le débat
va permettre de montrer les choses qu'on
n'avait pas vu avant et après on compte
sur la démocratie pour rattraper le coup
par exemple de des mois supplémentaires
plus élevés pour les femmes que pour les
hommes c'est des choses qui vont
peut-être se rattraper dans le débat et
quand le gouvernement
considère que cette réforme est
nécessaire qu'on ne peut pas s'en passer
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ce
postulat et est-ce que vous considérez
que c'est une bonne option de passer par
un amendement de de l'âge légal plus de
la durée de cotisation alors le fait
qu'elle soit nécessaire ça dépend là
encore de quel point de vue puisque 10
13 milliards par an de déficit sur un
330 milliards de dépenses c'est pas
grand chose mais ça s'accumule si on
fait rien et sans Mignard ou 150 en 15
ans ça commence à faire beaucoup le
gouvernement de la nuit lui-même qui
avait d'autres voies possibles
l'augmentation des cotisations sociales
faire contribuer le retraité actuel il y
a deux façons auxquelles on peut on peut
penser l'une c'est le gel des retraites
c'est déjà fait dans le passé mais ça
touche tous les retraités l'autre c'est
alignement des taux supérieurs de CSG
qui sont le taux le plus élevé et moins
élevé que pour celui des actifs là il y
a quelque chose les 10% d'abattement
pour frais professionnels accordés aussi
aux retraités il y a des marges de
manœuvre sur les retraites donc s'il
faut chercher l'argent on pouvait le
chercher ailleurs mais il y a des
questions économiques les questions
sociales des questions politiques pas
toucheurs traitées qui font que ces
personnes voientable je reprends la main
Stéphanie un mot là dessus sur le les
alternatives ou les parce que c'est vrai
que on l'avait il y a eu il y a eu une
première tentative de réforme des
retraites au début du premier
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron là il y a
un changement de pied qui est assez qui
est assez radical est-ce que c'est une
vieille réforme d'une certaine façon
est-ce que vous diriez ça en tout cas
c'est du rafistolage en fait c'est pas
on peut pas parler véritablement de
réformes de notre système de retraite
c'est pas ça une réforme hein c'est
juste essayer de de ça a été clairement
dit il faut retourner à l'équilibre
d'ici 2030 il nous faut 13 milliards et
bien on en a on rallonge la période de
cotisation et ça fait que on
a priori on aura un petit un pécule de 6
milliards supplémentaires la redistribue
à la redistribuer Mathilde lamousse sur
les on va on va évoquer avec vous
analyser les erreurs de communication de
du gouvernement sur cette réforme des
retraites oui Thomas c'est Olivier Véran
qui annonce un mouvement massif qui ne
s'attend pas à moi en massif et qui
finalement est contredit
manifestants c'est le Ministre Franck
Riester on en a parlé qui reconnaît à la
télévision que cette réforme pénalisera
un peu plus les femmes et c'est aussi le
président qui se met en avant et qui
nous dit depuis Barcelone qu'après tout
les Français ont validé sa réforme en
les lisant une seconde fois président en
réalité cette réforme elle comporte un
double passif à la fois celui de l'échec
du précédent quinquennat on en a parlé
mais aussi celui de la du renoncement à
la promesse initiale puisque au tout
début Emmanuel Macron voulait tout
revoir le système finalement Emmanuel
Macron nous donne le sentiment de faire
ce les autres avant lui une mesure
financière plutôt technique et l'erreur
originelle a été de la présenter comme
la mère des batailles d'en faire un
totem de son autorité politique à la
fois sur le plan national comme
international mais alors dans son
programme de sa réélection on l'a déjà
dit plusieurs fois je le rappelle
c'était même 65 ans c'était 65 ans et
c'était d'ailleurs la seule mesure
quelque part qui était à peu près
audible dans cette campagne mais qui
était aussi très impopulaire depuis
cette campagne le gouvernement a donné
le sentiment aussi de travailler et de
préparer en chambre c'était les
ministres d'un côté avec les syndicats
qui menaient les concertations et autres
parts l'objectif absolu de décrocher le
soutien politique DLR donc voilà des
tractations qui ont quelque part laissé
le pays et aussi ceux qui n'était pas
convaincu de côté à côté du débat et le
triptyque brandit la semaine dernière
par Elisabeth borne équilibre justice
progrès et chaque jour un peu remis en
question parce qu'on le voit avec des
des effets pervers dont on a parlé ici
finalement avec ce texte évidemment le
diable se cache dans les détails et dès
la présentation par Elisabeth borne on
sait tous demandés voilà à quel comment
est-ce que ça allait vouloir dire tout
de suite donc finalement le gouvernement
échoue à poser un cadre collectif
puisque cette réforme est renvoyée à nos
cas individuels si on creuse encore un
peu pourquoi cette pédagogie
gouvernementale elle ne prend pas on a
un argument qui est aussi beaucoup mis
en avant celui de vouloir à tout prix
sauver le système et pourquoi ce n'est
pas efficace parce qu'on sait que cette
réforme vous l'avez dit elle n'est
qu'une étape une adaptation finalement à
notre système actuel et donc on en aura
d'autres réformes à l'avenir c'est le
prisme financier la présentation
financière qui domine d'ailleurs on voit
beaucoup les ministres de Bercy Gabriel
Attal Bruno Le Maire et après le quoi
qu'il en coûte l'argument budgétaire il
ne convainc pas vraiment il a plus de
mal à convaincre est-ce que le Président
de la République peut rectifier le tir
maintenant la focalisation elle est sur
le mouvement du 31 janvier la première
ministre Elisabeth borne va devoir
monter davantage au front en fait cette
entrée en mêlée cette entrée en matière
sur les retraites elle révèle aussi les
failles du dispositif politique
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est à dire une
majorité qui est de plus en plus fragile
et une communication qui n'est ni pensée
ni coordonnée c'est comme si le
président Emmanuel Macron partait à la
guerre sans véritable soldat derrière
lui alors que pour être accepté c'est
très forme doit avoir une finalité
claire et un chemin aussi balisé pour y
arriver ça a changé plusieurs fois
depuis 2017 donc finalement le résultat
c'est que le doute s'est installé en une
semaine sur la capacité du président à
aller au bout de cette réforme merci
Mathilde pour cette analyse il y a eu
une information de de ce mardi fin
d'après-midi grève reconductible à la
SNCF à partir de la mi-février en tout
cas c'est ce que ont annoncé ce que
souhaite deux syndicats la CGT cheminot
et
Raphaël Legendre alors là c'est
intéressant parce que même si on
rebondit sur la communication du
gouvernement on a souvent entendu
Olivier Véran faire la différence entre
manifestation négociations et blocage
donc là on peut rentrer dans cette phase
de blocage avec un effet sur l'opinion
qui va rester à analyser qui est pas
simple d'ailleurs on peut pas
aujourd'hui dire qu'elle est fait ça
aura mais si on regarde un peu dans le
rétroviseur ça a toujours été un moment
un moment clé de la bagarre autour d'une
des retraites toutes réforme de retraite
en tout cas est un moment de
mobilisation très fort très intense et
très puissant depuis les années 90
effectivement après il peut y avoir un
effet retors c'est-à-dire que la
dernière journée de mobilisation du 19 a
beaucoup mobilisé plus d'un million de
personnes dans la rue c'est supérieur à
ce que attendez la plupart des membres
du gouvernement qui t'abais plutôt
autour de 700 000 personnes donc c'est
une bonne surprise pour les syndicats on
a beaucoup mobilisé les gens sont sortis
sauf que attendant de voir la suite
c'est à dire que plus le départ est
élevé plus le risque de descendre est
important et il est peut-être plus
avantageux pour les syndicats pour les
partenaires sociaux de peut-être
commencer plus bas et de monter en
puissance au fur et à mesure la pression
s'accélère alors sur l'exécutif
l'affaire davantage que ce million sans
à peu près de personnes dans les rues la
semaine dernière ça va être compliqué
donc avoir pour la suite c'est une grève
qui est assez peu suivie dans le privé
pour l'instant c'est beaucoup une grève
dans les services publics attendons de
voir le 31 janvier ce que ça donnera
avec Bruno pallier peut-être des
stratégies un peu différentes d'un
syndicat à l'autre
la chose à voir c'est que dans toutes
les mobilisations des sur les réformes
précédentes il y a eu une profession qui
s'est mise en grève et apporter un peu
le flambeau du côté des grèves donc les
cheminots en 95 mais les profs en 2003
par exemple donc il y a eu comme ça une
profession donc avoir là donc il y a des
cheminots qui qui cherche mais du côté
de l'énergie c'est peut-être aussi l'un
qui a de la mobilisation possible
deuxième point qui avait beaucoup porté
le mouvement en 95 c'est ce qu'on a
appelé la grève par procuration là on a
les éléments dans l'opinion publique
d'une opinion publique plus que
majoritairement opposé au principe de la
réforme donc le principe de la
délégation est là troisième élément
constitutif c'est l'interaction c'est à
dire qu'un mouvement réagit aussi à ce
d'en face en l'occurrence là le
gouvernement et s'il y a ouverture de
porte et chercher à faire des
concessions sur certains points il y a
la possibilité de dessoufler la chose ce
qu'il faut bien voir par contre c'est
que c'est la première fois au lycées
sont totalement unis
depuis 12 ans mais sur une réforme des
retraites c'était pas si unique ça en 95
donc sur toutes les réformes des
retraites et précédemment soit on
attaquait que une partie donc la réforme
de 2007 par exemple c'était les régimes
spéciaux uniquement soit on cherchait à
avoir avec soi une partie des syndicats
en 2003 là c'est la première fois et
donc la stratégie d'opposition frontale
en tout cas quand Emmanuel Macron vous
l'avez rappelé à Barcelone a dit je
resterai avec des terminations c'est
quand même là monter l'élévation de fond
et ça c'est ça nourrit l'idée d'une
montée en puissance du côté de du
Molière c'était très important parce que
on a quelque chose d'assez inédit
c'est-à-dire que la méthode Elisabeth
borne a été d'abord de consulter en
amont très bien mais surtout de tout
mettre sur la table le 10 janvier cette
réforme elle est connue elle est carrée
à la C4 piliers on a distribué
redistribué 6 milliards un tiers plus à
peu près un tiers des gains de la
réforme qui fait que la réforme
d'ailleurs ne garantit pas l'équilibre
si on regarde à la virgule près en 2030
il n'y a plus il n'y a plus de grains à
moudre pour l'assembler et pour le Sénat
c'est très clair il manque déjà un
milliard pour arriver à l'équilibre en
2030 donc ce ne sont pas sur des piliers
d'autant plus que Emmanuel Macron a dit
très clairement que la limite la ligne
rouge était pas d'augmentation d'impôts
il reste donc plus que quelques sujets à
la marge si je peux le dire sur la
pénibilité sur les rachats des
trimestres qui pourraient discuter mais
ce sera sans doute assez minimum on va
parler des soutiens politiques au
Parlement à l'Assemblée et au Sénat dans
dans une ou deux minutes mais
je reviens je vous donne la parole sur
le la mobilisation la forte mobilisation
de jeudi dernier effectivement est-ce
que ça change forcément la stratégie
gouvernement c'est pas totalement
l'impression qu'il nous donne pour
l'instant oui moi je pense que l'opinion
publique en fait descend dans la rue
parce que on explique qu'il faut
travailler deux ans de plus mais on n'a
pas expliqué pourquoi faire en fait et
passer de 62 à 64 ans les salariés comme
les entreprises savent très bien les
risques qu'ils prennent collectivement
c'est à dire que
lorsqu'un senior arrive à l'âge de la
retraite il devient moins attractif pour
l'entreprise parce qu'il coûte plus cher
et qui commence à aussi à se fatiguer ça
aussi des secteurs il y a des secteurs
où la compétence est valorisée avec
l'âge mais il y en a d'autres en fait où
la productivité ralentit donc
l'entreprise a tendance à regarder
le même profil en plus jeune parce que
c'est moins cher et ça va et donc c'est
une réalité le salarié et au courant et
à conscience de ça et l'entreprise aussi
or voilà les le gouvernement a dit on
décale de ces purement financiers on a
besoin de deux ans de plus de travail à
deux ans et débrouiller
la question de l'emploi des seniors
avant de éventuellement
on n'a pas essayé de d'inciter les
entreprises à trouver en fait des
solutions à part la publication d'un
index donc ça va on sait que ça va rien
faire et accompagner si aussi
l'idée c'est de d'accompagner trouver
une solution plutôt que de sanctionner
une entreprise vous voyez c'est ça c'est
pas comme ça que on valorise une
croissance et une économie c'est trouver
en fait des études sorties qu'elles
soient par des baisses de cotisations
pour rendre l'emploi des seniors
attractifs ou aller moi ce que je prône
vers du temps partiel pour qu'on aménage
en fait que le l'actif qui passe petit à
petit à l'inactivité c'est à dire à la
retraite qui est prévue dans la réforme
la proportion des retraités qui
travaillent ces 4% donc il y a quand
même une immense
à développer
le l'âge moyen de départ en tête on sait
que la réforme de 2010 qui a qui qui a
passé l'âge légal de 60 ans à 62 ans a
permis aussi d'augmenter de deux ans
l'âge moyen de départ
convaincre l'opinion publique on peut
pas dire vous savez ça va marcher de
souvenirs mécanique je pense que les
gens se disent qu'est-ce que je vais
faire pendant deux ans supplémentaires
non dans ce pays c'est le moment
ce qu'on dit jamais c'est 93 qui en fait
celle qui durcit le plus les règles en
passe de 37 ans et demi à 40 ans on a
donné lieu à aucune manifestation
pourquoi parce que il y a eu un
véritablement une négociation un échange
avec les syndicats à l'époque bah la
dure a dit je crée le fond de solidarité
vieillesse qui sera financé par la CSG
par de l'impôt pour financer non pas le
minimum de retraite mais le minimum
vieillesse c'est-à-dire ce qui est perçu
comme du non contributif les syndicats
ont dit top là ça veut dire qu'on ne
paiera plus des charges indus voilà donc
on a un exemple d'échange 2003 ça passe
parce que la CFDT finit par signer et
d'ailleurs pour le coup c'était mal
prévu puisque les prestations
la réforme est passée et alors c'était
pas très bien calculer moi je crois que
c'est important ce que vous avez dit
c'est que la sanction c'est pas ça qui
marche les pays qui ont réussi à
augmenter rapidement le taux d'emploi
des seniors c'est des pays qui ont
investi dans la formation qui ont
investi dans l'amélioration des
conditions de travail qui ont investi
une campagne publique pour pour
valoriser les cheveux gris les seniors
c'est la Finlande en quelques années
vraiment en quelques années ils ont
augmenté le taux d'emploi de des seniors
mais c'est positivement c'est pas juste
avec du coercitif avec un index et si
t'es pas bon c'est fini donc il y a des
choses à faire de ce côté-là je reprends
la main on va parler effectivement de
l'aspect très politique des voix des
députés LR je propose et des sénateurs
je propose à Quentin calmer nous
rejoindre bonsoir Quentin bienvenue pour
faire adopter cette réforme on sait que
le gouvernement compte sur les les voies
DL alors ça s'annonce un petit peu plus
compliqué que prévu exactement puisqu'en
fait on l'a vu en présentant sa réforme
ils avaient de borne à tout de suite
donné des gages à la droite par exemple
en actant des mesures demandées par les
LR l'exécutif c'est ainsi calé sur les
64 ans votez au Sénat depuis 2018 il a
accepté d'élargir les 1200 euros pour
les petites retraites aux retraités
actuel une demande de là encore formulée
par les républicains mais voilà
aujourd'hui au lendemain donc de la
présentation au Conseil des Ministres de
la réforme les journalistes France Inter
ont appelé les députés un par un au
groupe LR et coup dur pour le
gouvernement regardez la droite est
divisée sur les 62 députés et que compte
le groupe 15 annonce aujourd'hui voter
pour 16 10 assumées de voter contre
alors cette abstention 4 indécis et 20
ne se prononcent pas quand on les
appelle au téléphone de quoi donc faire
grincer des dents au groupe LR du Sénat
écoutez Roger carotic rencontre ce matin
ils disent qu'ils vont voter contre
avant même le débat parlementaire alors
attendons quand même que ce texte arrive
à l'Assemblée et voir comment se déroule
le débat nous nous avons déjà dit sur le
principe de la réforme why not oui ma
maîtrise de l'anglais mais en revanche
nous avons des amendements sur les
carrières longues sur les femmes sur les
carrières arrachées donc nous attendons
que le gouvernement naturellement sur
ces éléments-là fasse preuve d'ouverture
voilà on l'entend à Thomas il y a des
conditions y compris c'est chez les LR
dispositif carrière longue les
dispositifs pour les femmes et les
carrières hachées que feront-ils si ils
ne tiennent pas gain de cause ou que
partiellement dans l'hémicycle un petit
mot bonne question sans les LR le
gouvernement aurait-il une majorité pour
faire passer pour voter cette réforme
non pas dans les tags actuels des forces
en présence à l'assemblée nationale
regardez si on regarde tous les missiles
maintenant pas seulement le groupe LR la
majorité absolue en ce moment elle est à
287 députés vous voyez c'est qu'en bas
pour l'heure ils sont 264 à soutenir
ouvertement le texte sur l'additionne la
majorette la majorité présidentielle
c'est à dire Renaissance horizon modem
et donc les 15 députés LR ils sont 271 à
être contre si on additionne la nuque le
RN les 16 allers qui ont dit être contre
le groupe pilote avec des élus
d'outre-mer et donc si on voté demain la
réforme n'y aurait pas de majorité pour
l'adopter et même chose au Sénat on a
attendu que là aussi il faudrait
négocier avec les sénateurs merci
Quentin pour toutes ces explications
Raphaël Legendre ce cas c'est assez
étonnant le ce que ce que déjà obtenu le
groupe LR et ce qui cherche à obtenir il
y a beaucoup de sucrés pour reprendre
votre
terminologie alors qu'il trouve la
mesure encore trop bute ou trop brutale
pardon pour beaucoup ce qui peut
surprendre de la blague de la part d'un
parti de droite et de la droite de
l'écoutez absolument mais sont des
députés qui ne doivent leur élections
qu'elle leur propre personnalité et qui
pour beaucoup sont
issus de circo qui sont un peu compliqué
socialement c'est par exemple le cas
d'Aurélien Pradier qui lui est sa fiche
très clairement contre cette réforme du
rallongement de l'âge légal qui lui
était plutôt sur une accélération du
Touran l'allongement de la durée de
cotisation mais donc vous avez à
l'Assemblée un groupe républicain qui
sera non pas en soutien ou pour
renforcer en quelque sorte le rendement
de cette réforme mais plutôt pour la
douce y quelque chose de compliqué ce
qu'on découvre la ce matin effectivement
avec nos confrères de France Inter c'est
que là
il y en a qui se prononcent pas donc bon
avec Matignon et l'Élysée sur un deal
pour les retraites et bien on se rend
compte et les la majorité se rencontrent
que ce sera peut-être plus compliqué que
prévu y compris avec des voix
dissonantes au sein même de la majorité
l'algo là on a compté on a compté toute
la majorité présidentielle il y aura
peut-être
Dupont qui sont assez critiques avec
cette réforme également donc c'est très
clairement pas gagné cette réforme ça
veut dire que effectivement si le
gouvernement n'a pas les LR n'a pas n'a
pas le total de ces voix au sein de la
majorité ça veut dire qu'on se
dirigerait vers un 49-3 ce qui est tout
à fait possible puisque c'est un texte
budgétaire mais démocratiquement ça
changerait vraiment et politiquement ça
changerait beaucoup de choses y compris
pour le président pour ces réformes à
venir et pour la suite du quinquennat et
puis on a bien compris que c'est ce que
souhaitait a priori éviter ils avaient
de borne utilisait le 49-3 Bruno pallier
dans dans une tribune publiée chez nos
confrères du monde je crois que c'était
le 12 janvier vous craignez que cette
réforme attise une colère sociale qui
nourrit le rassemblement national
pourquoi alors c'est un raisonnement en
trois temps le premier temps c'est il
est toujours difficile de tracer un lien
causal entre une réforme et les votes
aux élections suivantes mais on sait par
le passé que les réformes des retraites
étant très visibles très discutées il y
en impact concret et là en l'occurrence
ça va être un impact concret rapide les
gens font un lien ça c'est le le premier
point le deuxième point c'est de
regarder qui est le plus concerné et qui
est le plus concerné sans compensation
c'est les ouvriers c'est les classes
moyennes pas très qualifiées qui elles
ne vont pas avoir de de compensation on
sait que dans ces catégories là on est
plus
on est plus probable de voter pour le
rassemblement national
la montée du vote Front national c'est
du côté des ouvriers du côté des classes
moyen pas très qualifié donc là il y a
un vivier et ça risque de d'alimenter la
chose troisième point c'est que Marine
Le Pen a déjà montré son talent
politique si je lui dire puisque sur les
gilets jaunes elle a eu la même position
qu'actuellement c'est à dire je soutiens
mais je n'instrumentalise pas vous me
verrez pas dans la rue vous ne verrez
pas organiser les choses de façon à ce
que je sois pas rejeté mais je sais très
bien que je peux tendre ma Sébille
électorale un prochain élection parce
que pas mal de d'études ont pu montrer
c'est pas tous les gilets jaunes mais il
y a une partie qui s'est traduite
dernier point finalement c'est l'Italie
en Italie madame Fornero présente une
réforme des retraites en pleurant en
2013 parce qu'elle savait qui allait
être concernée que ça allait être brutal
au sens très rapide quelques années
après cinquo Stella et la Ligue 1 donc
deux parties extrêmes alors là qui se
situait anti-système et l'autre à
l'extrême droite clairement gagne le
pouvoir notamment sur un programme qui
visait et qui a remis en cause la
réforme des retraites imposée
brutalement donc voilà c'est des choses
qui sont tout à fait pensables
on a été un deuxième tour où on a eu été
surpris par par les scores ou le faible
écart entre Emmanuel Macron et Marine Le
Pen je crois que là il y a quelque chose
à prendre en compte dans les calculs
politiques que peuvent faire les uns et
les autres il nous reste quelques
minutes dans ce débat j'aurais qu'on
parle des régimes spéciaux alors il y a
volonté de la part du du gouvernement de
mettre fin à l'inégalité des régimes
spéciaux c'est ce que la première
ministre et Elizabeth borne avait dit le
10 janvier lors de la présentation de de
la réforme ça veut dire quoi c'est fait
vibration prend un peu le détail il y a
notamment cette clause du grand-père
c'est à dire que ça concerne ça
concernerait les nouveaux arrivants la
suppression de régime spéciaux les
salariés actuels est-ce qu'on pourrait
dire allez je vais mettre les pieds dans
le plat les salariés actuel de la RATP
ou d'EDF par exemple qui ne serait pas
concerné sont font partie des gagnants
de cette réforme des retraites
puisqu'ils ne sont pas concernés
bah oui si vous voulez oui ils vont
effectivement de voir moins travailler
que les autres mais ça change pas le la
problématique de ces régimes spéciaux
qui pèsent quand même lourdement en fait
sur notre régime qui le rend largement
déficitaire c'est-à-dire que le privé si
on regarde que le privé le régime le
système est pas déficitaire
c'est un peu plus compliqué que ça le
régime général peut l'être de la CNAV
mais les le régime complémentaire
c'est-à-dire agir Carco le secteur privé
et ne peut pas de toute manière être en
déficit et même à constituer une réserve
de plus de 60 milliards c'est pour ça en
fait rappelez-vous Emmanuel Macron
voulait fusionner tout les régimes parce
que il y avait effectivement cette manne
à récupérer de tous les régimes
complémentaires qui auraient pu éponger
en fait les déficits de notre régime
général on comprend bien que les
partenaires sociaux qui gèrent
les régimes complémentaires on dit non
attendez nous on est dans la on a bien
fait notre travail dans la rigueur
budgétaire vous pouvez pas aller
diluer nos efforts pour le plus grand
nombre et puis c'est toujours le même
problème je pense que les régimes
complémentaires tant qu'ils voient que
les régimes spéciaux perdus avec qui
sont assez régimes là en fait qui
coûtent le plus cher qui pèse le plus en
fait proportionnellement sur sur le
système de retraite tant que ça n'a pas
bougé il n'y aura pas de révolution à
attendre de notre système de retraite
par répartition Raphaël Legendre cette
clause du grand-père elle est-ce qu'elle
vit en partie de sens la la fin des
régimes spéciaux annoncés par par
Isabelle borne par le bas bien sûr c'est
une réforme pour dans 43 ans rendez-vous
compte et on aura certainement le temps
d'allonger encore la durée de cotisation
d'ici là donc on l'annonce elle avance
tranquillement il faudra très
certainement l'accélérer quoi qu'il en
soit c'est très certainement la plus
grande des injustices aujourd'hui de
cette réforme le sujet non adressé
régime spéciaux qui très franchement
pour la plupart n'ont plus lieu d'être
vu les conditions de travail actuel et
qui coûtent encore plusieurs milliards
d'euros par an à la collectivité Bruno
pallier à moi là-dessus on voit que on
parlait de marge de manoeuvre tout à
l'heure quand on veut à la fin des
marges de manœuvre c'est le temps qui
fournit des marges de manœuvre
c'est-à-dire en combien de temps on met
en œuvre quelque chose là c'est
effectivement pendant très longtemps il
y a vous me posiez la question de savoir
est-ce que c'était nécessaire oui on
peut pas laisser courir un déficit comme
ça éternellement est-ce qu'il y a
urgence par rapport ou quoi qu'il en
coûte par rapport à d'autres sujets
c'est là où il y aurait une marge de
manœuvre potentielle pour amener les
gens indiens un problème mais on voit le
résoudre avec avec un petit peu de temps
l'autre point c'est aussi de pour la
population aujourd'hui il est très clair
que c'est la partie la moitié inférieure
de des groupes sociaux français qui sont
mobilisés aujourd'hui et donc la
question c'est de trouver des marges de
manœuvre pour dire on met à contribution
tout le monde c'est-à-dire la partie
inférieure qui de toute façon avait dans
l'esprit
vous allez travailler plus longtemps et
qui sont en forme pour le faire et qui
ont une espérance de vie supérieure à la
moyenne tous les gens assis autour de
cette table par exemple et
on parle de cette réforme sans se sentir
en fait complètement concerné ça les
Français le savent aussi merci beaucoup
de tous ces détails débats et c'était à
la fois contradictoire et respectueux
c'est tout ce qu'on aime sur le plateau
de sens public je tiens je vais rappeler
le titre de votre livret formé les
retraites ou nos paliers publiés aux
presse de sciences